so this is obviously your first like a
role in a movie of this scale and scope
what what did you expect going in and
what was it actually like on set to make
a film like this
i don't even know what i expected going
in i was terrified going in of just
being like oh my god because i didn't
know what to expect um
but it was an awesome experience um it
was definitely very different than than
you know doing a tv series and sort of
the
the workload as well as
i guess the particularly the physical
workload um and you know doing stunts of
that magnitude and that scope um
was
everything i'd always dreamed of and
like nothing i could have ever imagined
um
i'm a black belt and karate and so that
was something that i was very excited to
tackle um but it
it definitely took me out at points um
but it was just an awesome experience
all around yeah i i can't even imagine
especially getting to like you know uh
uh punch tom and everything else you
know
yeah
definitely like i apparently like so as
a journalist told me earlier that uh he
like i had kicked him really hard in our
like first like rehearsal together and
he never told me and i feel really bad
about it because like it was very
difficult for me to sort of like slow
to
not hit somebody when my brain for 12
years was trained to no but if you're
hitting something you're hitting it
anyway yeah
i could go on for what yeah
you get to play a real badass in this
movie um how much fun is it actually
playing a badass is it as cool as i
think it might be it's definitely very
cool like surely very cool um i did have
difficulty though a bit with braddock um
just in the
you know we as humans were empathetic
beings and so to have a to you know
portray a character that has no empathy
and no regard for anyone um was
a fun challenge but definitely a
challenge of of learning like no you
don't care you don't you don't care
you're just gonna get it done
um but yeah
everybody should play a villain at some
point in their life this game has sold i
mean tens of millions of copies around
the world it's incredibly popular for
fans of the game what are you most
excited for them to see actually in the
movie i'm excited for them to get sort
of
well first and foremost like nate and
sully's first adventure which you don't
really get to see in the games of like
where they sort of
start um and in our modern world like to
bring
to to be for that to be made real for
them like for me it was very exciting to
do it in the reverse of you know reading
the script working on the film and then
playing the games and like i'm like oh
okay yeah the tangibility of it is i
think it's going to be really exciting
for everyone um and the the hero
costumes was something that i was
personally really excited about so i
hope that
they get excited as well last question
for you i would imagine there were some
challenges filming this movie there's
challenges on every film what sequence
or shot ended up being the real pain in
the ass
definitely that fight with tom and i um
on the boat and that leaning boat
was so difficult like to try to run
back and forth doing this full and we
actually had the you know the boat on on
a rig that was at about 45 degrees maybe
a little steeper um i sustained a few
injuries from that day
um and it was just a hell of a ride it
was it was a few days that we had to do
it
um
yeah i would say that that was
definitely the most challenging bit um
but still fun all the same
uh again congratulations on the movie
great to talk with you and good luck
with the rest of your speed dating
thank you so much steven i really
appreciate that have a wonderful rest of
your day
you